FOR HIS FIRST NHL GAME.
KEITH, THE SEVEN-GAME PO ARE UN
PETERSEN.  HE INTERFERED AND
THERE SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
PENALTY PRIOR  TO CLEAR.
DANAULT TORISTOLAINEN
. THE FLYERS HAVE BY
ARVIDSSON.
THIS LINE CONTINUES TO GIVE THEO
KEMPE.
SHOTS ARE PLAY . HERE IS CAM
BACK . GIROUX  HE TAKES IT IN
THE  REDEFORE THE
CHANGE.
A BOUNCER, REBOUND, ON
QUICK WHO CANNOT PENGUINS.
YANDLE COULD NOT GET BACK TO.
AND THE KINGS KEPT ON GOING
MAYHEW   Jim: E.
HE LOOKS LIKE AN ALL-STAR
AGAINST THE FLYERS THIS YEAR,
THREE GOALS.
>>>>IS ATKINSON,AND COUGH
IT UP.L  AND THE
KINGS ARE ASSERTING THEMSELVES
AND HERE THEY THE MIDDLE.
THE SHOT IS DEFLECTED OUT OF
PLAY.
>> Keith: THE
THIRD.
THEY GET IT BACK TO ROY WHO
COULD NOT MES FREE,  TO KOPITAR
IT UNDERNEATH  CARTER HART.  FI
OPPORTUNITY.
TO GET A VICTORY
LAUGHTON .